a stack of books is a great example of
the stack data structure if you make a
stack of books the topmost book in the
stack was the one that you put there
last if you remove that book from your
stack stop you would expose the book
that was put there before the last book
stacks are a first-in first-out type of
service the last book you put on top of
a stack would be the first book you take
off the stack another example of the
stack is your browser's back button if
you look up here we just opened up
facebook.com so we add it to the top of
the stack of sites that we've already
visited previously when you stack top
push-push is one of the staff methods
you push Facebook on top of the stack
this middle is what it looks like when
we are visiting Facebook and then this
bottom image is where we press the back
button to navigate back to Twitter so we
pop off the most recent URL and we just
leave Twitter at the top of it the
function is traditionally provided in
the stack our push for placing data onto
a stack pop for removing the top element
of a stack peak for displaying the top
element of a stack and length or size
for determining how many elements are on
a stack a nice feature of JavaScript is
that the array object already has all
the functions we need in order to use it
as a stack so you could just use an
array as a stack I will show you how to
do this using an array but then I will
actually create a stack class and show
you how that works too I'm gonna use an
array stack to find words that are
palindromes a palindrome is a word that
is spelled the same forwards and
backwards such as Bob b.o.b or racecar
RAC eca are okay so we have our letters
equals an empty array and that's the
stack because remember I said arrays are
have all the functions of a stack so
look at how this program works first
we're gonna set a word to be anywhere we
want and we're gonna choose race car
which is a palindrome and then we are
going to have a variable which is just a
empty string for our word or reversed
word
we're going to use the stack to fill up
the r-word variable with the reverse of
the word variable the first thing we're
going to do is put the letters of the
word into the stack so we have a for
loop here and we're going to start at
index 0 and go to the last index of the
word length so an index in a string is
just which character we're looking at so
we're going to do letters which remember
is our stack dot pushed the step
function where you put something on top
of the stack and we're going to push
word index I so that's just going to
take this for loop is just gonna take
each letter of our word because we have
an X 0 and X 1 and X 2 each letters new
index and push it onto the letter stack
now we are going to pop off the stack in
reverse order so we can create the
r-word variable which is the reverse of
the word variable another for loop and
now we are going to have the r word and
we're going to add one letter at a time
from the stack by popping off the top
letter and because they were put in
order they're going to be popped off in
reversed order now we have a string that
should be the reverse of the first word
so word and our words to be reverse of
each other now to check it's a
palindrome we just say if our word
equals equals equals words it is a
palindrome over else it's not a
palindrome so let's run that and see
what happens and race card is a
palindrome but if we change that to free
code yeah and run that nope it's not a
palindrome okay that was just a basic
usage of a stack using an array now I
will show you how to implement a stack
in JavaScript so you can understand
stacks a little more you probably would
never do that because you can use an
array as a staff but this should
possibly help you understand how stacks
work a little better so here's where
we're going to create the stack which is
going to be this function here we're
going to have two variables this that
count
and this starts storage now this storage
is an empty object and count is gonna
keep track of how many items are in the
stack so here are all the different
methods we have pushed this step push is
going to add a value to the end of the
stack you're gonna pass end the value
this that storage or storage is the
empty object at the index this that
count we are going to add the value so
we're gonna put the value on the top of
the stack or the end of the stack and
then we're just going to increment count
up one so now it's showing that we have
another item in the stack the next
function we're going to remove and
return the value at the end of the stack
we're at the top of the stack which is
the stuff top this is gonna pop an item
off so if this that count equals equals
zero that means there's nothing of the
stack and we're going to return
undefined because there is nothing in
the stack once we return undefined we're
not gonna do anything the rest of this
code here because we've already returned
from this function if we're popping off
something we're going to have to
decrement the count so it's a count
minus one so one less we're gonna set
the result to this storage which is the
object for our stack and an index
discount which is the last item in the
stack and then we're going to delete
that item and we're gonna return result
so you get the last item back but it
will be deleted off of the stack and
there's just a few more methods this
that size is going to return this that
count which is the number of items in
the stack and then the last function is
this that peak which is going to return
the value at the end of the stack but it
will not remove it like pop so peak and
pop are kind of similar but pop removes
item and peak does not remove the item
so return this that storage and in this
that count minus one this that count
would actually be though index one after
the final item because what that's
really would add a new item but you
would have to do minus 1 to get the last
item and if you're peeking you do not
want to pass in a value so let me take
that bad off there so you only pass in
the value when you're pushing in
something
let's see how this would work down here
okay we are going to create a variable
called my step which is a new stack
which is what we just defined up there
we're gonna push one on to it to the top
that one we put two on the top so it's
just a stack with one and then two we're
going to peak and we're gonna have to
console dot log this because it's going
to just return the top number of the
staff which should be two now we're
gonna pop off too so it's going to
return to again but it's gonna remove it
and if we peek
we should be back to one and before we
run that I forgot these extra
parentheses here because these are
functions and need the parentheses at
the end of all functions so let's try
that okay see we peaked at two we popped
off two and then when we peaked again it
was one because two was was removed now
you can also add other things to the
stack
now I'm going to push a string onto the
stack and we're going to check the size
then want a peek and I'm gonna pop it
off anyway a peek again so let's see
what that does
so he pushed one we push to repeat with
show two we pop whoosh pop off too
we peaked again which showed one so
there's only one thing in the stack then
we pushed free code camp to string and
we console dot log the size and now this
item to the stack is just one on the
bottom and then three code camp on the
top we're going to peek which is going
to show freako camp now we're going to
pop which is going to pop off and show
freako camp and they're gonna peek again
and we'll see that it's just one on the
bottom well those are the basics of
stack thanks for watching my name is
beau Carnes don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good